the uncharted franchise has a
comprehensive timeline that spans six
mainline games a comic book a motion
comic and a book plenty of flashbacks
and even a flash forward and that's not
even counting the movie which basically
charts its own path but tom holland
aside how does uncharted all tie
together well it's relatively
straightforward for the most part i say
for the most part because well the
timeline kind of jumps all over the
place with flashbacks from uncharted's
three and four before it kind of sails
down so with the uncharted movie cherry
picking the greatest hits of the entire
franchise what better time to dive back
into nathan drake's saga of pirates
treasure lost city superhuman yeti
people and weird curse zombies
yeah remember them this is the complete
uncharted timeline fully explained
[Music]
so chronologically speaking the first
time we meet nathan drake or technically
nathan morgan at this point he's a
weeded lad at a saint francis orphanage
he's just like any kid his age he likes
playing hide and seek climbing and
breaking and entering maybe that last
one's because of the bad influence of
his big bro sam who whisks him away from
the orphanage to steal back their
recently deceased mother's belongings
including her precious journals you
ready for this
hell yeah
they recover their mum's journal but are
caught by the owner of the house they've
broken into who turns out to be an old
colleague of their mum an explorer named
evelyn who regales them with tales of
their ma and her research into the
legendary francis drake evelyn isn't
long for this world though and collapses
as the morgan lads are about to make
their exit the only thing complicating
that plan though is the fact that evelyn
has called the cops and the boys make a
hasty exit before they go down for the
death of their mum's friend
after their narrow escape the brothers
adopt the surname of drake in honour of
their mother's research but probably
also because of the fact that they're
wanted for a whole load of crimes
related to the death of evelyn but the
first one seems more appropriate
fast forward a couple of years and we
catch back up with a teenager eight in
cartagena colombia where he's attempting
to steal the ring of sir francis drake
from a museum exhibit but turns out this
sullen looking man with a mustache is
also after the ring nate tails him and
pickpockets a key to the drake exhibit
which he later uses to nick drake's ring
in some mysterious contraption as well
but just as he's getting to grips with
it he's ambushed by the mustachioed man
and budget helen mirren who turns out to
be catherine marlow the ruthless leader
of an ancient sect known as the order
who also has her sights on tracking down
francis drake's secrets nate manages to
escape only to be cornered by gunman who
seem surprisingly willing to gun down an
actual child you're all right
[Music]
what are you shaking for as he prepares
for this franchise to be over before
it's fully started mustar swings by in
the nick of time to save him the pair
later make acquaintances in a bar where
mustache introduces himself as victor
sully sullivan the man the myth the
legend who thankfully will be seeing a
lot of across this franchise because
he's freaking awesome enough sally love
for now but don't you worry there will
be more nate fills sully in on his
search for a long lost treasure that
once belonged to sir francis drake and
the pair start a long and fruitful
friendship
nearly a whole decade passes before we
catch back up with nate where 20
something drake is milling about a
panamanian jail turns out he's there
with his big bro sam and their treasure
hunting mate rafe adler and with a name
like rafe you just know he's going to
turn out to be a rongan they're
searching for clues for a long lost
stash of pirate treasure that once
belonged to the great pirate captain
henry avery drake scours some old prison
ruins and discovers an old wooden cross
sporting saint dismiss the penitent
thief which points them in the direction
of a scottish cathedral their attempt to
escape the prison quickly goes south and
as they're making their exit sam is shot
and falls to his apparent death well at
least that's what nate thinks for
basically his entire adult life but
let's not get ahead of ourselves
[Music]
next up in our timeline we've got the
uncharted comic which was released back
in 2011 and 2012 but featured a few new
characters that had already been
established in the franchise at that
point chief among them is one chloe
fraser an indian australian treasure
hunter who is more than a match for our
nate the uncharted comic charts nate and
sully's first meeting with chloe as the
trio raced to unearth a place known as
the amber room which turns out to be a
part of a long-lost city known as
agartha which lies underneath the north
pole the city was home to an advanced
civilization that was wiped out by a
bizarre race of monsters known as the
smoking gods canonically the first
supernatural force that drake comes up
against but there will be plenty more
either way nate and co find and then
escape the city as it crumbles around
them a trope that will crop up a fair
few more times before this video is
over the pocket adventure of uncharted
golden abyss takes place next in our
chronology and sees drake journey to the
jungles of south america in search of
the lost city of quivera nate teams up
with archaeologist dr marissa chase in
the search who's also personally
invested as her grandfather vincent
perez has disappeared in the process of
trying to solve the mystery of quebec's
whereabouts and find the golden abyss
standing in their way is a whole platoon
of mercenaries and an entire
revolutionary army led by all-round bad
eggs jason dante and roberto guerrero
who are in league with each other aguero
has other ideas though and double
crosses dante and kidnaps marissa of
course among it all drake follows clues
most of which involve you using the ps
vita's touchscreen functionality
that
which leads him to the ruins of quivera
where he discovers the golden abyss is
actually a cave network of gold-lined
caverns that have been irradiated by a
nearby uranium deposit nate and marissa
escaped the ruins before sealing the
irradiated gold forever with a good
old-fashioned batch of tnt another
ancient city destroyed forever job done
[Music]
all right we are nearly at the
franchise's first proper game drake's
fortune but taking place just before is
the motion comic prequel eye of indra i
of indra sees drake looking to source
the funds for his upcoming adventure to
race sir francis drake's coffin more on
that very shortly to make ends meet he
takes a job from american crime lord
daniel pinkerton to track down the
titular artifact a bejeweled pendant
drake with the aid of a woman named rika
deducts that pinkerton actually already
has the pendant without knowing it it's
located within another indra treasure
that's currently situated within
pinkerton safe and instead of just
telling the ruthless crime boss drake
makes the risky move to steal it from
him instead to accomplish this rika
brings in her brother who turns out to
be eddie raja the quick-tempered pirate
who we later meet in uncharted drake's
fortune but i'm getting ahead of myself
again the trio successfully nabbed the
eye of indra and make it to safety
only for rika to double cross both nate
and her brother the motion comic ends
with nate commiserating with sully and
detailing his plan to secure the funds
for his drake expedition a plan that
involves one elena fisher
[Music]
right we are finally at the very first
game in the franchise uncharted drake's
fortune which kicks off with nate's
aforementioned expedition to dredge up
the coffin of sir francis drake drake is
assisted by documentary filmmaker elena
fisher in tracking down the coffin to a
location off the coast of panama where
they discover the coffin without a
corpse but with drake's incomplete diary
before they can sift through it for
clues they're ambushed by pirates and
have to be saved by sully who arrives in
a badass flying boat which just screams
adventure to me god damn it i love sully
drake's journal turns out the goods
though kicking off the trail to a little
something known as el dorado you might
have heard of it nate and sully give
elena the slip and head into the jungle
following drake's clues they discover
that el dorado isn't a place but a thing
a cold statue a huge cold statue
following the 400 year old trail of
drake and the spanish conquistadors nate
and sully happen upon a german new boat
in the middle of the jungle where nate
finds the last remaining page of drake's
diary and a map that points them to an
uncharted island somewhere in the middle
of the pacific ocean they're not the
only ones after el dorado though they've
got competition from the likes of fellow
treasure hunter gabriel roman and
mercenary atoc navarro who promptly
shoots sully and takes the map nate
escapes with his life and he and elena
chart sully's awesome flying boat
towards the uncharted island and the
treasure of el dorado on route the pair
crash land on the island and navigate
their way across it on foot and aboard a
particularly irritating jet ski
they also come up against an unpleasant
surprise in the form of our old pal
eddie raja and his troop of pirate goons
who are also working with navarro and
roman to scour the island for the el
dorado monument a more pleasant surprise
is that sully's still alive and after
nate and elena rescue him he reveals
that roman and navarro were coercing him
to help them discover eldorado too
reunited the trio unearthed some secret
passages underneath the island's ruins
that eventually lead them to the final
resting place of sir francis drake
and a horde of monstrous zombie things
oh crap yeah i did say there was gonna
be more supernatural [ __ ] in this
timeline whatever these things are
they're known as the descendants and
they promptly chow down on poor eddie
which to be honest is no great loss the
underground secret passages eventually
lead nate to a german u-boat base where
he discovers that hitler's finest
discovered the secrets of eldorado too
but here's the rub the statue is
actually a coffin and it's cursed all
hell with some terrible ancient plague
which we see in action when roman opens
it before immediately turning feral
navarro shoots and kills roman and
reveals his ultimate plan to steal the
coffin and use the plague as a buyer
weapon which sounds like a bit of a
risky ploy but whatever fortunately nate
and co stopped navarro in his tracks
sending him to the bottom of the pacific
with his cursed coffin prize too and
with that done and dusted nate sully and
elena journey off into the sunset with a
boatload of gold
three years later we catch up with nate
in one of the most iconic openings to a
game ever
[Music]
flashback to earlier that year and nate
is chilling out in a beach bar where
he's approached by fellow treasure
hunters harry flynn and chloe fraser who
proposition him with a job that could
lead them to the lost fleet and treasure
obs of juan marco polo
hey check it out marco
really come on
no marco
the first part of the job takes them to
turkey where they steal an oil lamp that
holds a handful of weird blue resin
along with a treasure map that points to
borneo but to absolutely no one
surprised because flynn has a british
accent and all brits are inherently evil
drake is double-crossed and left for
dead in a turkish prison he's eventually
bailed out by sully and chloe who inform
him that flynn is working for a serbian
warlord called zoran lazarovich and that
they've discovered the lost fleet in
borneo but digging a little deeper the
trio realized that the trail goes beyond
that and leads to the discovery of a
lifetime a giant gem known as the
chintamani stone and the fabled lost
city of shambala the trio traveled to
borneo and successfully sabotaged
lazarovich's lost fleet dig site what do
you say we really ruined this guy's day
before discovering an ancient tibetan
dagger and a map that points towards a
temple in kathmandu nepal and that sadly
for all our sully fans is where he bows
out of this game
after escaping the dig site nate and
chloe head to war-torn nepal where they
bump into of all people elena fisher and
her cameraman jeff who are in the city
documenting the whereabouts of
lazarovich the quarter eventually end up
at the temple thereafter and nate
reveals to elena exactly what they're up
to so let me get this straight you're
competing with a psychopathic war
criminal for a mythological gemstone
when you put it that way it does sound
pretty stupid yeah thanks for the input
jeff yeah thanks jeff nate and chloe
eventually discover a map room in the
bowels of the temple and using the
tibetan dagger as a key find the
location of shambhala but as they
attempt to escape the war-torn ruins of
the city they're caught by lazarovich
who promptly shoots poor jeff sorry mate
and makes off with chloe the dagger and
the map to shambala nate and elena then
trail the serbian into the mountains in
the greatest action sequence on a train
you will ever see slash play seriously
this blew my mind back in 2009
nate eventually catches up with his foes
and grabs the dagger back before flynn
shoots him and leaves him for dead among
the ruins of the great train action
sequence trademark
nate wakes up healed and rested in a
tibetan village in the house of village
leader tenzim he also makes
acquaintances with a german lad called
karl schaefer who was on a similar
expedition to discover the city of
shambala 70 years earlier nate and
tenzin venture off in search of the
previous expedition and discovered it
was actually a nazi tour and schaefer
murdered his ss comrades to keep the
secret of shambhala safe from the world
that's not the only bombshell though as
the pair are ambushed by a horde of
superhuman yeti men and only just escape
with their lives as they travel back
they see that lazarovich has attacked
the village nate and elena help tenzin
fight back and secure the village before
they follow the serbian warlord deeper
into the tibetan mountains there they
discovered the entrance to the lost city
of shambala a city guarded by the
aforementioned yeti men who it turns out
have got their powers from the
chintimani stone which is actually the
heart of the tree of life
wow that's a lot of process lazarovich
the evil bastard that he is wants to
harness the power of the tree of life to
turn himself into a superhuman because
of course he wants to naturally nate
aims to stop this and in the process he
shoots the explosive blue resin at the
heart of the tree of life and you
guessed it destroys another ancient lost
city
[Music]
sandwiched between uncharteds two and
three is the official tie-in novel
uncharted the fourth labyrinth but
because i can't really show you footage
of a book in my video let me try and
break down the story as fast as i can
nathan and sully track down the fourth
labyrinth in an adventure that takes
them from new york to china by egypt and
greece long story short they find it
it's not very good and the guy on the
cover doesn't even look like drake and
to my knowledge doesn't ever duel will
guns in the story but don't take my word
for it right on with the rest of the
timeline
[Music]
right first a word on some essential
plot points that happen between
uncharted 2 and 3 and have absolutely
nothing to do with that rubbish book
first the big one nate and elena get
married at some point pre-uncharted 3
and subsequently separate because nate
is a raging commitment phobe and
secondly elena quits her burgeoning
documentary career and becomes a foreign
correspondent right life admin out of
the way what ancient city does drake
destroy in this game in short the city
of uba or the atlantis of the sands
uncharted 3 kicks off with nate and
sully teaming up with chloe fraser an
all-round cockney-wise guy budget jason
statham charlie cutter so which door's
scary pop inside him behind to dupe
catherine marlow and infiltrate her
london-based hq there they discover the
journal of t.e lawrence as well as sir
francis drake's cryptic puzzle device
that's been in marlow's possession ever
since the early 90s piecing all the
clues together from both t lawrence and
drake's journals points them towards the
immeasurable wealth of the lost city of
ubar which is located somewhere in the
middle of the rubalkali desert in saudi
arabia to find out exactly where though
they need to travel to a french chateau
and a syrian fortress because this is an
adventure and we need exotic locations
to explore nate and sully head for
france where they discover one half of
an amulet at the heart of an abandoned
chateau but just as they are making
their escape they're ambushed by
marlow's right-hand man talbot who sets
the building ablaze and nate and sully
only just escape with their lives ah man
that was close huh they hightail it over
to syria fearing that chloe and qatar
are in harm's way too but luckily find
them unscathed there the quartets sneak
past marlow's thugs to find the other
half of the amulet in the ruins and the
complete amulet points them to their
next clue which is located in yemen as
they're trying to escape though qatar
gets drugged and is forced to hand over
the amulet to marlow he's saved by nate
and co but breaks his leg as they flee
the ruins forcing him and chloe to back
out of the venture which is a shame his
cutter was an underrated top lad oh [ __ ]
nate and sully soldier on though and
they traveled to yemen to link up
somewhat reluctantly in nate's case with
elena who has been stationed in the
country after a brief sightseeing tour
of the city the trio eventually discover
the location of the tomb containing
their next clue where they find a
veritable feast of giant puzzle rooms
including this creepy chamber of limbs
and discover the location of uber but as
per usual they're ambushed again by
marlow's men and nate is drugged like
qatar was previously sending him a
little mad
don't touch me
and so begins a mad chapter of the
uncharted franchise where nate is
captured by a pirate named ramesses
aboard a giant cruise liner that
capsizes all while trying to save sully
who turns out to be a mannequin and not
even on the ship drake does drake things
and survives by the skin of his teeth
and makes it back to elena who informs
him that sully has been kidnapped and
taken into the desert with marlow it's
absolutely bizarre but a lot of fun bay
hatcher planned to stow away in a cargo
plane which nate boards in the nick of
time but he soon discovered which
triggers another epic uncharted
set-piece trademark that was copied
nearly beat for beat in the uncharted
movie where the plane crashes in the
middle of the desert
miraculously drake survives only to be
marooned in the middle of the rubal
khali he travels around and around in
circles before finding a ghost town
that's conveniently inhabited by marlo's
desert-bound entourage drake who by this
point is basically a one-man army fights
them nearly all off before he's rescued
by a platoon of horsemen led by saleem
back at their camp saleem regales drake
with the legends of uba telling him that
the city is cursed because king solomon
trapped an evil gin within a brass
coffin and threw it into the water
supply as you do nate is hell-bent on
finding sully though and asks for help
tracking marlo's caravan and saleem
reluctantly agrees the pair launch an
ambush on the caravan in a sequence that
riffs heavily on indiana jones in the
last crusade actually come to think of
it the whole of uncharted 3 rifts
heavily on the last crusade sorry back
on track nate rescued sully and the pair
trail marlow and talbot to uber there
they discovered that the legends of ubar
that celine mentioned are somewhat true
albeit there's no gin magic it's all
just poison water that sends the drinker
into a manic hallucination which
explains a lot don't touch me nate and
sully foil marlow's plan to dredge up
the brass coffin which somehow sets off
a train reaction of explosions which yep
destroy the ancient city
nate and sully make it out by the skin
of their teeth but marlowe and talbot go
down within the sinking sands nate and
sully then make it back to yemen and
meet elena again and the two embrace are
they back on the cards spoilers yes
[Music]
and that leads us to the events of
fanshawed for a thief's end which sees
our treasure hunting husband and wife
team out of the game and living the
domestic life nate's working for a
salvage company elaine is back working
as a journalist and the pair do normal
married things together like eat dinner
on the sofa and play crash bandicoot
jump jump stop yelling oh what happened
is that it
although it's clear that nate pines for
that one last job and just such an
opportunity comes swinging by in the
form of his long-lost brother yep the
thought to be to see sam is back and he
wants back in on the treasure of henry
avery turns out he's also under the
thumb of a drug lord named hector
alcazar who he's promised a share of
aviary spoils fortunately he has a lead
to a similar cross that the pair found
back in the panamanian jail a lead that
takes them to italy where they hatch a
plan with sully to steal it in the
process of stealing the cross they
bumped back into their old pal rafe
adler who's teamed up with a merc called
nadine ross and they're after the cross
as well long story short nate secures
the cross and he sam and sully deduce
that the next clue they seek is in
scotland near to the cathedral that rafe
has been scouring for years there they
find a trail of clues and tests left by
henry avery for pirates seeking out
paradise for those who prove worthy
paradise awaits which turns out to be
the legendary pirate utopia of
libertalia nate and sam pass the various
tests and find a giant floor map which
leads them to a volcano in madagascar
they travel to madagascar and track down
their next clue coordinates to an
uncharted island in the indian ocean all
while leaving a hefty trail of death and
destruction in their wake
enter elena who's tracked her renegade
husband down and is rightfully pretty
pissed with him for lying to her about
what he's been doing the whole time and
the fact that he never mentioned he had
a brother after a pretty heated argument
nate doubles down on finding levitalia
to the disdain of sully who leaves a
check on elena nate and sam head for the
pirate coordinates which leads them to
henry avery's narcissistic piradent i
mean he has a giant statue of himself
one clue leads to another and the giant
pirate statue literally points the way
to the island haven of libitalia the
brothers drake eventually discover the
pirate utopia and begin to search
through the ruins for the treasure their
search is put to an end by the arrival
of rafe and nadine and a whole load of
explosives that bring half the city down
because this is an uncharted game ray
finally gets the drake boys at gunpoint
where he reveals that there is no hector
alcazar the drug lord and sam has
actually been working for him before
going rogue reef then shoots sam in the
shoulder which knocks nate over a cliff
after a flashback to his time as a child
which we covered earlier he is woken up
by elena who's come searching for the
pair with sully nate and elena continue
on through the ruins of libertalia with
their adventuring working like a weird
form of marriage counselling they
eventually work their way to the poshlad
district of the pirate colony where they
discover the truth behind what went down
with avery and his crew namely avery
grew tired of sharing in his wealth and
vision and sought to escape with his
treasure nate and elena eventually link
back up with sam and sully and discover
avery's treasure in a giant pirate
galleon ship in a hidden natural harbour
there nate duels with rafe who has gone
blind with lust for the treasure and for
his troubles gets buried in a big old
pile of gold
[Music]
nadine on the other hand being the smart
one of the two escapes with her life as
does nate but it's a close run thing
that genuinely had me thinking that
naughty dog were actually gonna kill
their leading man instead they give
their hero a happy ending nate and elena
head home where elena buys the salvage
company nate works for with a bundle of
pirate coins that sam snuck into her
luggage and the game ends with a couple
thinking ahead to their next adventure
in life only it doesn't but before we
get to that lovely conclusion we've got
one last adventure to regale
set roughly a year after the events of
uncharted 4 the lost legacy is our first
adventure without nathan drake instead
we follow the unlikely team-up of chloe
fraser and nadine ross as they search
for the legendary tusk of ganesh in this
pursuit they come up against the
ruthless warlord assad who is also after
the fabled treasure their adventure
takes them deep into the jungles and
mountains of india as they follow one
clue to another and eventually discover
the location of the tusk only they're
beaten to the punch by asav and his men
who have been coercing sam drake into
using his treasure hunting prowess to
help their malevolent aims asav takes
chloe sam and nadine as his prisoners
and leaves them to die as he makes off
with the tusk naturally they live to
fight another day and chase down a sav
and the tusk and finally face off
against him on a moving train ugh just
like old times before it goes over a
collapsed bridge taking a sab to a messy
death
couldn't have happened to a nicer guy
and now let's get back to that lovely
conclusion that i mentioned a bit
earlier which happens about 15 years
after the main events of uncharted 4
because yeah nate and elena have a
teenager called cassie and in an
extended epilogue sequence cassie
discovers the secret history of her
adventurous parents after discovering a
photo of nate sally and elena from the
end of their eldorado adventure back in
uncharted drake's fortune and the
franchise's timeline comes to an
incredibly wholesome end with nate and
elena regaling their many adventures to
their daughter on a family boat trip
all right guys that is the uncharted
timeline fully explained if you like
these kinds of deep dives into gaming
timelines please jump in the comments
and let us know what you'd like to see
next we've already got timelines for
halo metroid and resident evil on the
channel already thanks for watching and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you